golpe de estado-militar en guinea
conakry las fuerzas especiales guineanas
detuvieron al presidente alpha condé de
83 años en el poder desde 2010 según
confirmaron en exclusiva a france 24 el
presidente está con nosotros está en un
lugar seguro
se vio a un médico no hay problema
tenemos todas las fuerzas de seguridad
detrás de nosotros para acabar de una
vez por todas con la miseria del pueblo
guineano
efe un mal kinect después de varias
horas de incertidumbre y fuertes
disparos finalmente el líder militar
golpista anunció desde la televisión
estatal y envuelto en la bandera
nacional la disolución de la
constitución y el ejecutivo de co2 y su
la constitución hemos disuelto la
constitución vamos a disolver las
instituciones nuestro gobierno está
disuelto el cierre de las fronteras
terrestres durante una semana más y
vemos después cómo hacer con las
fronteras aéreas sólo un golpe de fox ya
adrián como ser cortés galván gas y
emprendemos una consulta nacional para
abrir una transición inclusiva y
pacífica
donde lleva más de 10 años en el
gobierno guineano el pasado octubre fue
elegido presidente por un tercer mandato
en unos violentos y polémicos comicios
acusados de fraudulentos por la
oposición
el mandatario se postuló después de
aprobar una constitución en marzo de
2020 para eludir el límite de dos
mandatos del país lo que generó fuertes
críticas y manifestaciones muchos
apuntan a que los últimos años conde
tomó una deriva autoritaria un argumento
defendido por los militares que se han
alzado en el poder la personalización de
la se acabó la personalización de la
política de la vida política ya no vamos
a confiar la política a un hombre vamos
a confiar la al pueblo ya la confiep el
depuesto presidente conde ya sufrió en
2011 un intento de golpe de estado poco
después de jurar su cargo tras las
primeras elecciones democráticas del
país desde su independencia de francia
en 1958
[Aplausos]